hello and welcome to collab week the
week where I fulfill my obligation as a
youtuber to perform some collaboration
videos for your enjoyment in this
installment I am joined by heartthrob
disc jockeys danisnotonfire and
amazingphil and we will be collaborating
through the medium of sculpture we're
gonna make some art now I just throw a
unicorn into the mix you can going
equestrian something with four legs
that's already very advanced Phil I like
unicorn is there anything we can add to
that I could take the black and make it
slightly robot unicorn and a rainbow
colored rainbow colored that works Wow
okay how about a different color for
each body part if it is proper squeeze
and a good roll I'm making a hoof this
is the first time I've engaged my
muscles Charlie our legs looking mildly
different which is not that's not quite
correct okay that's like a duck's foot -
Charlie there's not much of a who's why
they so flat at the bottom
that's what hooves look like what pop
look even if we don't say it everyone
watching this is thinking the same
looking it's they're they're colorful
phallic cliches beit's complete okay
half pink half yellow body so I start
building some kind of neck I feel like
that's too much pressure I'm gonna make
tail is that what a horse's tail is like
they're more like down aren't they well
they've got like a flare at the end like
a Charmander I'm most impressed by this
tail so I'm proud of the tail file it
just happens to also be the one thing
you can't see it's got the shape of a
horse it has the shape of a four-legged
animal and we're gonna go for red
forehead red head yeah I'm feeling that
does someone want to bring up a photo of
a horse
um no that's cheating imagine the help
the horse emoji like a simplistic horse
are you a fan of emoji Charlie in your
texts and yeah one of my favorite emojis
is the the dancing lady
yeah elsa lady kicking out a sassy heel
I feel like she encompasses a lot of
just general joy she's just having the
best time and so she is if you're having
the best time you can communicate that
to people
charlie that looks terrifying that looks
like a horse from Silent Hill what have
you done I don't think horses have quite
as big nexuses
that's a thick neck and pretty surely
the sauces on steroids it's not unicorn
yet oh no need the unicorn spike on the
front like I think why it's good here
obviously oh that's good twisting
Emily's going in with the twists that's
amazing then that could easily impale
someone I would buy that just the whole
yeah I love that this is our collective
we now need to work on the robotic
paneling do you have any blue left let's
take a bit out of his butt and put it oh
look at that pretty blue unicorn eye its
horn is drooping I've been performance
issues so there we go there is our
collaborative project yeah together we
created a Frankenstein rainbow robotic
unicorn yes I love it can we give it a
name is it male/female I feel I'm
feeling I'm feeling female my instinct
says Gertrude Isis also there's also a
robot it's the most inappropriate info
about Gertrude free
Gertrude three that's good cuz it's a
robot yeah how'd you feel like that they
don't speak about the first two Gertrude
can you now animate it now so it doesn't
break charges it often destroys worlds
oh thanks for having us charlie you're
welcome thanks for being in my
collaboration video for collaboration
week I had the best time I'm glad you
did
I'm glad you had fun I had fun good bye
now bye Internet right you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool thank you very much and if
you'd like to watch the other
collaboration videos from this week you
probably don't need me to tell you which
boxes to click on I'm sure you can
figure out for yourself goodbye